[Music]
stop you gotta get your breathing sorted
don't panic be calm be still
you've got to get your rhythm section
under control I can lose it
remember give your heart as the drums
your breathing as the bass you get those
sorted and you're sorted
as the drunks your breathing is the base
put another one in never less than two
good easy part
what's the hard part living with it
[Music]
so where exactly have you been for the
past few years
you're the information broker mock
well I know you're much more human than
I thought you'd be coachable and it's a
good discuss yes it is so what's your
story
you're from Munich I think you know I'm
from Berlin oh it's my bad it's just you
don't speak to the trace of a German
accent
[Music]
Carla Security's tight no gun will get
through not the way you're going in
wishes hell he owns a penthouse on
Central Park West not his family home
mistress hall girls gasp in first square
in the face okay are you listening hmm
when he goes down cut his throat
you go in deep you go in hard ear to ear
gas in first well you won't manage and
wait until you're undressed you got a
better idea
I don't have a worse one
I lost my family three years ago it
wasn't very accident there was a bomb on
that plane I need your help to find the
ones who did this
I've got nothing to lose what about your
life what about it I'm gonna say this
once even if you succeed it won't be
worth it I'll make every street walking
the streets promise me you won't do
nothing sir why are you here drop in
question I'm how would you do that
violently
[Music]
you're much more human than I thought
you'd be that's look of disgust
[Music]
eating the clothes about the scale of
the mess he cooks
[Music]
[Music]
did you see last night
[Music]
[Music]
in this film my character Stephanie lost
her family in a plane crash
she falls into drugs to cope with the
pain Pakistan was a bomb not plane she
goes on a mission to find out who did it
and why and try to avenge her family
that's really what changes her you can
do I need your help to find ones who did
this
I've got nothing to lose but your lies
about Stephanie opens the door and steps
through a life changing scenario what
she's done that she can't go back every
scene in this movie is life or death you
never know if she's gonna make it
she really is just a normal human being
who was thrown into this world
Stephanie said a character who is
burning on the inside when you take a
human life there is real pain there is
real consequence she carries a lot of
guilt for the things she's had to do
please don't please don't
throughout the film Stephanie really
struggles to find wholeness for her son
I'm gonna do this my way
even if you succeed it won't be worth it
basically wanna do this
[Music]